hey man what do you got for me uh so
i've read your book and uh i've listened
to you for a while but uh
the current situation i'm in i've uh got
out of an engagement nine months ago
uh to an attorney
sorry man
i was i was married to a lawyer
yeah so
anyways i you know i similar to the last
caller
uh you know i moved into her place and
you know basically you know beta data
station all that good stuff but i i made
the decision at the end of the day to
end it which is the right decision and
um
you know a lot of red flags that i
ignored myself and uh it's been nine
months and uh lost like 40 pounds you
know i uh i make you know i make great
money i'm in medicine
and uh
and i felt like i've been doing well but
i getting these kind of bouts in my head
where
i beat myself up you know
putting myself in that position
what do you mean putting yourself in
that position like meaning like you know
losing frame and uh losing yourself and
uh okay you know those those type of
thoughts and feelings and
um
and so you know i i do have these months
where i'm doing fantastic at work you
know i'm hitting the gym
uh you know i'm feeling great and i'll
have these bouts of like
negative thoughts you know not not like
harming myself but just negative
thoughts you know putting myself down
for
uh decisions that i made that put myself
in that situation right you mean like
you're going back to the
and what like questioning the time you
spent with her or do you have like
remorse for breaking up with her like
i'm not sure that i'm clear
i'm not regretting the decision but
wasted time waste of time okay uh you
know uh kind of the person i became at
the end of it even though i initiated
honestly it could have been done by
either one of us
and so how old do you know man i'm 35
you're 35 okay and how much time did you
waste with uh a lawyer girl
four years about four years yeah okay
well
think of it this way you got a four-year
education
without the
lit like lingering after effects you
know without the hangover you know you
didn't marry you didn't have kids with
her you didn't do anything you know like
beyond that it's like
listen you know you can lose or you can
learn in life and then and in every
difficulty in in every struggle there's
a silver lining um i've told the story
before i'll mention again there was a
there's a private equity investment that
i did on this house once and you
generally don't lose money on private
mortgages you generally
get about 15 percent rate of return with
interest fees statements and all that
sort of stuff
um you know in your cash and it's
secured because it's because it's you
know with a solid asset except for
i didn't vet a investment property
properly enough guy [ __ ] me over um
ended up costing me close to sixty
thousand dollars so i spent i don't know
a year and a half and sixty thousand
dollars learning how not to do a private
deal
every deal after that i made more money
on and i never made the mistake again so
it's like
you can't do anything about anything
behind you you can't do anything about
time okay there's only the time that's
left ahead of you right there's like
three boxes that you can stand in
there's past present and future you only
have two legs right you can put both
both feet in one box or you can put one
foot in one box in the other box and
it's like if you're standing in the
present and in the future as a man today
at 35
and you have these lessons you know
behind you
you've only got these two feet so if
you're going to spend time standing in
the past
then you're taken away from your future
you're taking away from you know being
present right now uh eckhart tolle the
power of now it's a good book you should
check it out a little bit
but i mean the point comes across there
right so it's like you can't spend time
milling over the past you can't cry over
spilt milk you know like they say
they've been saying this for millions of
years you see what i'm saying though
right yeah no i understand i i've been
um
breeding a lot of you know proctor
gallagher i don't know if you've helped
heard of him he's he's very into the
subconscious and conscious and the body
and the
you know like you're
basically you know the thoughts you have
enforce your subconscious and what you
manifest so
i'm fine with a little bit of woo-woo so
yeah
it's okay you know a little bit of woo
in your life and you know it balances
out some of the [ __ ] like
you know grunting alpha [ __ ] but you
know
um so so what's the ask here like is
this a share you know sort of thing or
is there a problem that we need to solve
here i think it's a share it's a share
uh because you know similar to your last
caller
i don't know where he's at but i've been
in that position where you know uh one
of the
i'm sure he's still watching so you know
you tell him what it is that you want to
say yeah basically i would say you know
uh
i i would i would not move into a
woman's home again i would say that sure
because they can use it over your head
which you know was done
and um
and uh and yeah i think when he's giving
examples of like the picking up the cat
vomit you know i've been in the position
where i realized things were turning
when i was in the bathroom and i was
critiqued on how i cleaned the toilet
at that point i was like okay something
has changed and it's time to leave so
it's important to understand those kind
of
those warning signs and uh you know like
you always say you know don't avoid red
flags in the beginning so those are a
lot of things i took away from your book
and which the last uh
the last person can take away as well so
well i mean like you were smart enough
not to
get too involved with her
and um
good for you you know you you
some guys
you know their intuition isn't isn't
there to protect them it it
it marches them into the slaughterhouse
you know like our last caller you know
he he's marched in the slaughterhouse
and he's still in there he's dodging
[ __ ] sharp things and
doing stuff like this and he's trying to
just trying to figure out how to get rid
of all the knives and sharp things that
are in the slaughterhouse and it's like
you can keep trying that man but i'll
tell you what you know again the theme
of the show is simplicity just get the
[ __ ] out of the slaughterhouse
right simple as that
all right man thanks thanks hey guys i
really hope that you enjoyed that short
clip if you did consider supporting the
creation of content by checking out my
supplement line pinned in the top
comment below of this video in the
comments there's a link to the unplugged
alpha dot com forward slash shop when
you click through you'll be able to land
over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you